As humans, we have evolved such that we're able to be aware of both our
internal world and our external world. This is what we mean by consciousness.
And we vary in our level of awareness and arousal throughout the day from when
we wake to when we sleep. Sleep is vital for healthy functioning, both
physiologically and psychologically. It allows our body to restore itself after
a long day of activity. In addition, sleep aids us in memory consolidation and
it helps us learn. Dreaming that occurs during REM Sleep also assists in brain
growth and development. Humans have a long history of taking psychoactive drugs
to change their consciousness. And we have many reasons why we take drugs
including recreational, social, spiritual, and medical or psychological
reasons. Depressants like the barbiturates, benzodiazepines and alcohol,
depress central nervous system activity. Therefore, they can cause relaxation,
and decrease anxiety. Opiates are very effective in treating pain. Stimulants
like cocaine and methamphetamine increase sympathetic nervous system activity.
Cannabis has been used medicinally. But it can also cause perceptual
distortions. The hallucinogens like LSD and psilocybin produce profound changes
in perception. Finally, although MDMA is also used recreationally, it is
showing promise as a new treatment for post-traumatic stress disorder.
Psychoactive drugs produce their effects by interacting with receptors, such as
dopamine and serotonin receptors. And they mimic our naturally-occurring
substances produced by the brain, such as our endorphins.